how much of the human brain
do you think we understand i think we're
at a
weird moment in the history of
neuroscience in the sense that
um there's a there
i feel like we understand a lot about
the brain at a very high level
but a very very coarse level
when you say high level what are you
thinking are you thinking functional are
you yeah
structurally so in other words what is
what is the brain
for you know what what what kinds of
computation does the brain do
um what kinds of uh
behaviors would we have to uh
would we have to explain if we were
going to look down at the mechanistic
level
um and at that level i feel like we
understand
much much more about the brain than we
did when i was in high school
but but it's at a very it's almost like
we're seeing it through a fog it's only
at a very coarse level we don't really
understand what the
the neuronal mechanisms are that
underlie these computations
we've gotten better at saying you know
what are the functions that the brain is
computing that we would have to
understand
you know if we were going to get down to
the neuronal level and at the other end
of the spectrum
we you know in the last few years
incredible progress has been made in
terms of
um technologies that allow us to see
you know actually literally see in some
cases what's going on at the
at the single unit level even the
dendritic level
and then there's this yawning gap in
between
oh that's interesting so at the high
level so that's almost like cognitive
science
yeah yeah and then at the neuronal level
that's neurobiology and neuroscience
yeah just studying single neurons the
the the the synaptic connections and all
the dopamine all the kind of
neurotransmitters
one blanket statement i should probably
make is that
uh as i've gotten older
i have become more and more reluctant to
make a distinction between psychology
and neuroscience
to me the point of neuroscience
is to study what the brain
is for if you if you if you're if you're
a nephrologist and you want to
learn about the kidney you start by by
saying
what is this thing for well um it seems
to be
for taking uh blood on one side
that has metabolites in it that are
that shouldn't be there uh sucking them
out of the blood
while leaving the good stuff behind and
then excreting that in the form of urine
that's what the kidney is for
it's like obvious so the rest of the
work is deciding how it does that
and this it seems to me is the right
approach to take to the brain you say
well what is the brain for
the brain as far as i can tell is for
producing
behavior it's from going it's foregoing
from perceptual inputs to behavioral
outputs
um and the behavioral outputs should be
adaptive
so that's what psychology is about it's
about understanding the structure of
that function
and then the rest of neuroscience is
about figuring out
how those operations are actually
carried out at the
at a mechanistic level that's really
interesting but
so unlike the kidney the the brain
the the gap between the electrical
signal and behavior
so you truly see neuroscience as
the science of that that touches
behavior
how the brain generates behavior or how
the brain converts raw visual
information into
understanding like unders like you
basically see
cognitive science psychology and
neuroscience is all one science
yeah is that it's a personal statement i
said i'm hopeful
is that is it a hopeful or a realistic
statement so certainly you will be
correct in your feeling in some number
of years but that number of years could
be
200 300 years from now oh well well
there's a
is that aspirational or is that a
pragmatic engineering
uh feeling that you have it's it's both
in the sense that this is what i
hope and expect will bear fruit
over the coming decades but it's also
pragmatic in the sense that i'm not sure
what we're
doing in either either psychology
or neuroscience if that's not the
framing
i don't i don't i don't know what it
means to understand
the brain if there's no if part of the
enterprise is not about understanding
the behavior that's being produced i
mean
yeah but i would compare it to maybe
astronomers looking at the movement of
the the planets and the stars
and without any interest of the
underlying physics
right and i would argue that at least in
the early days
there are some values just tracing the
movement of the planets
and the stars without thinking about the
physics too much because it's such a big
leap to start thinking about the physics
before you even understand
even the basic structural elements of oh
i agree with that i agree
you're saying in the end the goal should
be yeah deeply understand
well right and i i think so i thought
about this a lot when i was in grad
school because a lot of what i studied
in grad school was psychology
and i found myself a little bit
confused about what it meant to
it seems like what we were talking about
a lot of the time were
virtual causal mechanisms like uh
oh well you know attentional selection
then
selects some object in the environment
and that is then passed on to the motor
you know
information about that is passed on to
the motor system but these are these are
virtual mechanisms these are you know
they're metaphors they're you know
there's no they're not
there's no reduction to there's no
reduction going on in that conversation
to some physical mechanism that you know
which is really what it would take to
fully understand you know how
how behavior is arising but the causal
mechanisms are definitely
neurons interacting i'm willing to say
that at this point in history
so in psychology at least for me
personally there was this strange
insecurity about trafficking in these
metaphors
you know which were supposed to explain
the function of the mind
um if you can't ground them in physical
mechanisms then what you know
you know what is the what is the
explanatory
validity of these explanations and i i
um
i managed to uh i managed to
uh soothe my own nerves by thinking
about
uh the history of um genetics research
so i'm very far from being an expert on
the history of this field but i know
enough to say that
uh you know mendelian genetics preceded
uh you know watson and crick and so
there was
a significant period of time during
which people were
uh you know cons productively
investigating um the structure of
inheritance
using what was essentially a metaphor
the notion of a gene
you know and oh genes do this and genes
do that but you know
where the genes they're they're sort of
an explanatory thing that we made up
um and we we ascribe to them these
causal properties so there's a dominant
there's a recessive and then
then they recombine it and and and then
later there was a a kind of blank there
that was filled in
with it with a with a physical mechanism
um
that connection was made um but it was
worth having that metaphor
because that's that gave us a good sense
of what
kind of cause what kind of causal
mechanism we were looking for
and and the fundamental metaphor of
cognition you said is the interaction of
neurons
is that what is the metaphor no no the
metaphor
the metaphors we use in in in cognitive
psychology
are um uh you know things like attention
uh the way that memory works
you know i i retrieve something from
memory
right you know a memory retrieval occurs
what is that you know that's not
that's not a physical mechanism that i
can examine in its own right
but if we if if but it's still worth
having that
that metaphorical level right yeah so
yeah i misunderstood actually so the
higher level abstractions is the
metaphor that's most useful
yes but but what about
so how does that connect to uh the
the idea that that arises from
interaction of neurons
well even it is the interaction of
neurons
also not a metaphor to you is or is it
literally
like that's no longer a metaphor that's
that's already
that's already the lowest level of
abstractions that could actually be
directly studied well
i'm hesitating because i think what i
want to say
could end up being controversial so
what i want to say is yes the
interaction of the interactions of
neurons
that's not metaphorical that's a
physical fact that's
that's where that's where the causal
interactions actually occur
now i suppose you could say well you
know even that is metaphorical
relative to the quantum events that
underlie yeah
you know i i don't want to go down that
rabbit hole so is turtles on top of the
turtles yeah but it's better
there is there isn't there's a reduction
that you can do you can say these
psychological phenomena
are can be explained through a very
different kind of causal mechanism which
has to do with neurotransmitter release
and
and so what we're really trying to do in
neuroscience writ
large you know as i say which for me
includes
psychology is to take these
psychological phenomena and map them
onto
neural events um i think
remaining forever at the level of uh
description that is natural for
psychology
for me personally would be disappointing
i want to understand how
mental activity arises from
neural neural activity
but the converse is also true studying
neural activity
without any sense of what you're trying
to explain
uh to me feels like um
at best groping around uh you know at
random
you